[Musique]
c'est la plus prestigieuse des
récompenses individuelles en foot le
ballon d'or qui récompense le meilleur
joueur de l'année depuis 1956 année de
sa création ils sont quatre français à
l'avoir emporté zidane papin platini
copa le premier lauréat français c'est
lui raymond kopa milieu du real madrid
en 1958 à l'époque le ballon d'or
récompense le meilleur joueur européen
personne ne contestera jamais son
admirable technique sa couverture de
balle ses fans qui déconcerte et
l'adversaire et le public
france football à l'origine du trophée
lui consacre sa une quelques photos
témoignent de la remise du trophée mais
à la télé rien et à la radio non plus
écoutez la réaction de raymond kopa des
décennies plus tard c'était en 2014 ça
représentait vraiment que
beaucoup plus à ma famille que moi
peut-être enfin j'étais quand même très
heureux
ce n'était pas facile après copa il faut
attendre 25 ans soit 1983 pour qu'un
autre français soit sacré
michel platini meilleur footballeur
européen de l'année michel platini
piliers de la juventus de turin au total
il en gagnera trois d'affilée une
première là aussi la télé minimise
l'événement pas de réaction de platini à
la télé les images sont rares le voici
avec son trophée c'était en 1985 au
musée grévin à paris enfin un dernier
hommage le ballon d'or qui le consacre
pour la deuxième fois meilleur
footballeur mondiale aujourd'hui c'était
platini superstar troisième français
ballon d'or jean-pierre papa en 1991
cette fois téléfoot consacre une
émission entière au buteur de
l'olympique de marseille jean pierre
papin reçoit des mains de michel platini
le sélectionneur national et de raymond
kopa ancien avant centre du real de
madrid le ballon d'or qui récompense le
meilleur footballeur européen de l'année
jean pierre papin succède au palmarès à
lothar matthaus sept ans plus tard en
décembre 1998 un autre français le
remporte qui est ce indice il a planté
deux buts en finale de coupe du monde
quelques mois plus tôt
le milieu de la juventus turin reçoit
son trophée lors d'une émission spéciale
au total trente minutes de direct sur
france 2 sur le plateau il est entouré
des autres ballon d'or france ils ont
fait ça me touche je sais pas quoi dire
ça chez nous un peu comme jean pierre
l'a été quand même me disais donc pareil
pour se contente d'être le quatrième
aujourd'hui être quatrième français à
avoir remporté à partir de 2007 le
ballon d'or est attribuée au meilleur
joueur du monde quel que soit son club
depuis zinedine zidane plus aucun
français ne l'a gagné
franck ribéry s'en est approché en 2013
terminant troisième tout comme antoine
griezmann en 2018
[Musique]